well we first told you about a mass
overpayment notification that went out
to unemployment claimants
on tuesday well now many nevadans are
finding themselves stuck with really not
knowing how to appeal the notices
because many of them feel they never got
the money in the first place let alone
pay it back
joe moeller is live with what people are
saying tonight about it joe
well some people say they're having a
difficult time trying to find that
appeals button when it comes to these
overpayment notifications others we
spoke with
say they already have some appeals in
review so now they can't
do yet another appeal on these
overpayment notifications that they're
getting
i said it's not going to happen i'm not
sending you back
a penny barbara brighton is an
entertainer she can't work due to the
virus and was on unemployment
this week deter sent her a notice of
overpayment
that means they want money back i got
two letters
stating that i had to return two
separate numbers
she says they want about fourteen
thousand dollars by the end of the month
she says it isn't right and she wants to
appeal the letters but
there is a problem there's no link that
says you can appeal it
not that i saw it on overpayment it just
says
pay it she says she can't figure out how
to appeal it on the website
others we came across are running into
similar problems twenty thousand
sixty two dollars is the total uh they
want me to repay
sarah spanrio already filed two appeals
but now it won't allow her to file a
third as
the first two are in review i lost my
job due to
the pandemic and i've continued to be
unemployed due to the pandemic
and i just don't understand why i don't
understand why
this is really basically where i'm at
now we did reach out to dita regarding
these situations were expected to hear
back today but hopefully we'll get those
answers tomorrow we also did talk to
a woman who runs a popular uh a facebook
page that helps people on
unemployment are trying to get answers
she says maybe if you head to the main
page and just click on the unemployment
services tab
and trial trying to file an appeal there
that might work she says others have had
some luck there
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now